[Music]
john is in fairfield connecticut hey
sean what's up
hey dude hey anthony how are you guys
doing well man how are you
good thanks i was looking to get uh your
guys's advice on
something i graduated college back in
2019
and uh back then i was a little bit
ignorant about student loans and i have
about
150 000. i was lucky to get a job and be
employed before the pandemic struck an
unfortunate time to have income around
75
000 i've been living with family
rent free for now but as i approach the
end of my second year
living with them i'm looking forward to
moving out and getting out on my own
financially however doing out my budget
i feel stretched in
and i feel like i'm unable to afford a
rent payment along with everything else
after student loans 401k contributions
some savings my car payment and sharing
some food costs
i'm left with around twelve thousand
dollars a month um which in my area is
sometimes not enough sometimes just
enough for a rent payment
so my question to you guys is what can i
do uh in order to move myself into a
better financial position where i can
afford to uh pay rain and continue to
stay within the bounds of my wage
or do you guys think i need to consider
making a professional movement in order
to get a wage boost
well here's the very first thing i
wouldn't tell you is that you said
something about your
student loans 401 contributions your
401k
contributions i want you to pause all
that i want you just to focus on baby
step number two okay so we're not going
to make any contributions and and i you
sound like very smart young man so now
you're probably thinking well wait
i'm missing out on the compound interest
well no you're not um
you technically are but then you're
gonna make that up in a long term
um after you pay off all your debt uh so
what i want you to do
is to do to just pause everything else
and focus on
just your student loan debt and all of
your debt
now cost of living i think we do need to
look at that to see where
where else can you move into i'm not
even opposed to you having roommates
with your
in your age bracket right now to kind of
lower your expense a little bit on your
living
expenses i do like the fact if you're
moving out of your parents house to
start your adult manhood
but maybe you can find your roommate to
kind of help with that rent as we're
going along this baby step 2 journey
what do you owe in your car
uh i owe probably about 12 000 on the
car
when did you buy that i bought that
august of last year
okay all right well rule number one for
getting out of that
is don't take on more
yeah it was sort of uh required for my
work my uh
98 jeep was getting a bit unreliable so
i needed something that could match my
commute
yeah no it would
your 98 jeep was getting you there and
it wasn't required
you just got to commute you're just
driving to work nobody requires you to
get a car to drive to work you just had
to have something reliable
now if your 98 jeep wasn't working you
can move up but you're not going to get
rid of the student loan debt
until you take debt off the table you
cannot solve your problems with debt
they make your problems bigger
and that's what the car purchase did so
you know if you didn't have a car
payment there'd be a lot more room in
your budget there'd be a lot more things
to talk about here
uh you didn't buy a super expensive car
so it's not something we have to sell
today
to get rid of it but that
decision-making paradigm has got to
shift
if you want to get ahead with money you
want to get rid of the hundred fifty
thousand dollars in student loan debt
you're gonna have to live on nothing
take on roommates
get rid of this car payment as soon as
you can that's the first thing
and then begin to pay on the student
loans as hard as you can now if you
can make a move in your field
and be in a less expensive area and make
more money
obviously those two things are going to
combine to
get you out of debt even faster and so
we want to do that we want to get rid of
the car payment and but you cannot be
borrowing any more money
yeah you've got to stop it is a you know
the only way out
is to stop yeah it's rule number one
and uh and you can't come up with any
rationalizations or justifications for
any reason
you have to stop cold and that's your
only shot on that
changes everything when you just take it
off the table it really does dave
when you take that off of the table you
start seeing more creative things and
how you can really
uh go about attacking debt not just
attacking that but even going after all
of your dreams
but if you keep racking up debt saying i
want to get out of debt but then you're
racking up debt you're just playing that
that circle circle
and it's just it's not going to go
anywhere so sean hang on i'm going to
send you a copy of our book the total
money makeover
which eight million people have read and
it will show you step by step
exactly what to do and
uh and how to lay these baby steps out
that we're talking about baby step ones
you save a thousand dollars
two is we're going to list these two
debts smallest to largest car then
student loan
uh and we're going to attack with a
vengeance uh
and you know we're not doing anything
except getting out of debt we're taking
extra jobs we're changing jobs
we're taking on roommates we're doing
everything and
uh you're gonna be in this a while and
so yeah i am moving out
now you're doing this now dave uh let's
let me ask you this question as a father
hunt your son has a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in debt he's living at
home with you
are you still asking him to leave after
a year being out of school or would you
allow him to stay in say all right if i
see a clear game plan
where you can get this off within two
three years
are you okay with that as a father no
gotcha no i i'm you don't hit the road
yeah um
because something happens when you move
out of the house right and you start to
handle this situation
now again you're always welcome if
you're wounded if there's a
horrible life event and you need a safe
place i'm not a hard
i'm not a hard butt in that regard but
150 000 making 75
is not you're not gonna do this quick
right and so you need to get out there
and start shoveling
yeah and you know figuring out what
you're gonna do from that that's not
being abusive it's just
when he when he starts owning this all
the different parts of it
emotionally spiritually and everything
else uh his tactics will change and then
he'll be a debt-free screamer on the
stage yes sir
and that's what will happen and i was i
was asking that question because i'm
pretty sure some parents are listening
saying well how come he just can't stay
at home
yeah you know he has all this debt you
know if he could do it for four months
yeah right but but you know if that did
it but four months or
or even a year doesn't make any
difference here right it does not change
the math
that substantially exactly and so uh you
know young couple
same age bracket uh on the debt-free
stage
last hour you know what they did yep
lots and lots of overtime
lots of it raised their income forty
thousand dollars in the household within
six months
anything that's what happens when you
got okay i've got to do this
yes and your brain starts going uh i got
to work someplace more
or different or i got to work more or i
got to you know i got to sell this thing
or whatever it is you start laying it
all out yeah and it just
it's a it's a it's a
uh the weight of being on that
the extra weight of being on that island
and saying oh wait a minute this is real
and it's all on me long ranger is not
coming i got to do this yes sir
and then you get then you get going
that's what happens